Usually, the best horror films earn their
scares with gradually escalating tension.
The following flicks, however, jump straight
into the scares before the audience even gets
settled in their seats.
Many of them are among the scariest movies
ever made, and every one of them boasts opening
sequences that are certain to have the faint
of heart nervously eyeing the exits.
These are some of the most terrifying opening
scenes in horror history.
It Follows
As one of the breakout horror film hits of
2014, everything about It Follows seemed designed
to keep the viewer permanently off-guard.
Its methodical pace mirrored that of its "monster,"
a relentless pursuer who could appear as anyone
and could only be shaken off by passing the
curse to someone else.
"See, everything's okay."
[Scream]
In its terrifying opening, we follow an obviously
traumatized young woman as she flees down
a street to the beach - and something else
is following her.
We don't know what it is yet, but we know
she's scared to death, and by the end of the
scene, we know it was for good reason.
Some viewers may have been put off by the
movie's ambiguous ending, but there was certainly
nothing ambiguous about its opening, a master
class in nerve-jangling terror.
Split
M. Night Shyamalan was on top of the world
after the success of 1999's The Sixth Sense,
and after a long rocky stretch, he returned
to form with 2016's Split.
This psychological thriller is anchored by
James McAvoy as Kevin Crumb, a disturbed man
with 23 different personalities - plus an
additional one only known as the Beast.
[Grunting]
The opening scene illustrates every teen's
worst nightmare, as a trip to the mall for
three teenage girls turns suddenly sinister
as Crumb nonchalantly takes his place in the
driver's seat.
IT
Stephen King's IT is widely regarded as being
among the finest of his standalone novels,
and its 1990 TV miniseries adaptation scared
the pants off of many a '90s child.
"Bring your friends."
[Evil laughter]
The opening scene, in which young Georgie
encounters Pennywise while looking for his
paper boat in a storm drain, is familiar to
many - which makes the version offered by
the 2017 adaptation all the more shocking.
Much of the film's pre-release speculation
centered on whether Bill Skarsgard would be
able to live up to Tim Curry's classic turn
as the evil clown monster, but that question
was answered definitively within seconds of
the appearance of those predatory eyes, floating
in the darkness of the storm drain.
It's an opening that would have been all too
easy to mess up - but instead, the sequence
established a vicious tone for one of the
best horror films of the year.
Halloween
John Carpenter's 1978 masterpiece gave birth
to a thousand horror tropes.
It was a film unlike anything fans of fright
flicks had ever seen - and that includes its
opening sequence, which put the viewer squarely
in the shoes of a maniac.
The scene leads us through the halls of a
suburban home, from the point of view of an
unknown person who dons a clown mask, grabs
a huge kitchen knife, and uses it to stab
a teenage girl.
The first-person point of view is only broken
at the scene's end, when the girl's parents
arrive home to find the murderer standing
on their front lawn - revealed to be the victim's
six-year old brother, Michael Myers.
"Michael?"
Carpenter would go on to a long and distinguished
career of scaring the living daylights out
of audiences, which anyone brave enough to
sit through the first five minutes of his
breakout hit could have easily predicted.
Cube
Released in 1997, Cube operated with a mind-bending
sci-fi premise that revealed itself gradually
after a stunningly effective cold open.
A man awakens to find himself in a cube-shaped
room with several apparent points of exit,
completely unaware of how he got there or
what he is supposed to do.
After finding all exits to be essentially
identical, he picks one and goes through.
And then…
The rest of the film features some similarly
violent scenes - but none of them blindsided
us quite so hard as the first.
The Hitcher
A young man picks up a hitchhiker by the side
of the highway, in the middle of nowhere,
on a dark and stormy night.
"My mother told me never to do this.
That's a pretty spooky premise on its own,
but 1986's The Hitcher quickly turns it into
something even more sinister with an opening
scene that left audiences with no doubts about
where the movie was going.
"Because I cut off his legs and his arms and
his head…
And I'm gonna do the same to you."
This opening scene introduces Rutger Hauer's
John Ryder as an agent of pure mayhem, and
Hauer's performance makes his previous turn
as psychotic replicant Roy Batty in Blade
Runner look positively endearing by comparison.
"Do you wanna know what happens to an eyeball
when it gets punctured?"
Evil Dead
Horror film fans had plenty of reason to be
wary of 2013's soft reboot of Sam Raimi's
classic Evil Dead.
But those fans had no way of knowing at the
time that the project was in the hands of
a major talent: writer-slash-director Fede
Alvarez, who made no attempt to rehash what
had worked in the previous series, but brought
a wickedly inventive tone all his own instead.
The film opens with a terrified young woman
being hunted down and captured in the woods
by her own family, who appear to be religious
fanatics bent on burning her alive.
But as her father fumbles with the matches,
the woman's tearful pleas take a hard left
turn - and it suddenly becomes obvious that
the only terrible mistake this family made
was not getting that fire started a lot sooner.
"I'll rip your soul out, daddy.
I'll rip your soul out!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!